( intro music )
( applause )
Wow...
Welcome everyone.
It's great to be here.
Now, there's one thing
that we know for sure
that nature is good for us.
We've known this
for millennia.
2000 years ago Daoist monks
wrote about
the healing powers of
working in greenhouses
and tending gardens.
And in 1984 E. O. Wilson
wrote about
our deep, primal need
to affiliate with nature
in the natural world,
and coined the term
"Biophilia".
This concept of biophilia
is becoming ever more urgent
as we consume the
biodiversity around us,
and separate ourselves
more and more
from the natural world.
As of 2010,
we have officially become
an urban species.
More of us live in cities
than don't.
And that is a trend that is
continuing and accelerating.
It has progressively
drawn us inside,
away from the natural world.
And now the average
North American and European
spends 90 percent
of their time indoors.
That remaining 10 percent,
well...
five of that is spent in a car
( audience laughter )
if not more.
I hear some commuters
laughing in the audience.
This is...
this is an environment
very different from
our ancestral origins.
And it's a relatively
modern thing.
So, how has this radical shift
in lifestyle affected
our minds and body?
Well, there are
a slew of studies
chronicling the
modern ailments
that go along with
the separation
from the natural world.
And there are...
physical as well as mental
and some of these include
spreading epidemic of myopia.
If you don't get enough
sunlight on your eyeballs
they grow longer
and we get myopia.
We have rising levels
of obesity and diabetes,
cardiovascular diseases
correlated with
a lack of nature exposure,
and all sorts of
behavioral disorders.
Depression is rampant.
So, what is going on
and how can nature help?
Well, nature is...
nature is a
complicated therapy.
It's not only rich in visuals,
it's multi-sensorial.
You have incredible sounds
and tastes
and textures, interrelationships
and processes...
It's...
it's a complex therapy.
How do you figure out
what's doing what?
Well, you can
start to look at it
by breaking it into
its component parts.
And, let's say visuals.
Now,
I'm a marine biologist and
I've spent many, many hours
studying this crazy fish,
the Giant Ocean Sunfish
and other large animals.
And I love being immersed
in nature.
I find it completely
exhilarating and rejuvenating.
But what I find
particularly interesting,
as well, is that just
looking at nature imagery
does something powerful
to our brains and bodies.
There's something going on
there, we're not in nature
we're looking at it.
So, what's that mechanism?
Well, Roger... Robert Ulrich
was the first
to really formally
write about this and
publish a scientific study
in 1984 in Science ,
in the journal Science .
And he found
that recovering patients from
gall-bladder surgery
who had windows
that looked out on trees
had a faster recovery rate,
upwards of a day faster.
And requested fewer
strong pain medication
than those patients
whose windows
look out on a brick wall.
And since those studies
many have followed suit
and found similar things.
There's a number of theories
that have been put forth to
describe and explain
what's going on
and one of the prevailing
theories is put forth by
Rachel and Stephen Kaplan,
of the University of Michigan,
that's called "Attention
Restoration Theory".
You have your
directed attention,
your voluntary attention and
your involuntary attention.
And nature, it has
our involuntary attention.
It draws us in
with this kind of,
what psychologists call
a "soft fascination",
that doesn't take much effort.
You look at the
clouds overhead,
you look at the wind
rustling the leaves
and your attention is drawn
but it's not taxing you.
As opposed to directed
attention where you're...
if you're driving,
you have to,
you know,
stay focused on these things.
And nature is
restorative in this way.
So, that's one of
the prevailing theories,
and there's lots of
different ones as well.
And there's ways
of testing this.
You can take...
take bits of saliva
and look for cortisol,
which is a measure
of stress levels,
you can put on
galvanic skin sensors,
heart rate monitors.
But what if you could
crawl right inside the mind.
Now wouldn't that be cool?
So, that's what
we're looking at now
and I'm coining-- I'm calling
this neuro-biophilia.
The science of how
nature engages the brain.
And this is a sub-discipline
It joins other sub-disciplines
that are looking at the brain
and how the brain responds
to our environments.
And they include things
such as neuro-cinematics,
the brain on movies.
There's also neuro-aesthetics,
the brain on beauty and art.
And what I find
really exciting
about these
sub-disciplines is that
they're highly
interdisciplinary.
They're drawing from
all sorts of different venues,
all sorts of
different disciplines,
from social science to
evolutionary psychology to...
to computer science,
artificial intelligence,
landscape architecture,
color theory and
they're pulling it all together
to make sense of what's
going on in the brain.
We have our toes on the shores
of this vast cerebral sea
and it's such an exciting time
to have these tools available
for these explorations.
And to continue our
adventure into the brain,
I'm going to hand off to Tan.
So, thanks for listening.
( applause )
Thank you, Tierney.
And, good evening everyone.
You know I spend
most of my day
in front of a computer screen.
I basically do
a lot of reading,
I look at a lot of numbers,
measurements and
I coordinate people
because I've spent the
last ten years of my life
working to develop
new technologies
that allow us to study brains.
You know, this amazing
and yet enigmatic space
inside our head.
And as we go through life,
our brain actually undergoes
extraordinary development.
It's the most adaptive
organ in our body.
And it can change both
positively and negatively,
by our thoughts,
actions and experiences.
And we know,
as neuroscientists that
nature has a restorative
effect on the brain.
And the way in which
most of these experiments
are conducted is based on
giving people a
sustained attention task
that drains and fatigues
your attentional networks.
And then you're asked
to spend about 30 minutes or--
in nature or in
an urban setting
and then you're brought
back into the same place
and asked to do
the same test again.
And you're measured
to see your performance,
which one did you do better in.
And whilst that's
a really good way to
observe the effects of
the beneficial effects
of nature on the brain,
it's not quite the
same as being able to
measure and quantify exactly
what is going on
in the brain itself.
And that's the question
that the three of
us wanted to answer.
We wanted to actually
measure and quantify exactly
what is going on in my brain
when I experience those
amazing imagery of nature.
And, so one of the things that
really excites me the most
about brain research
in the last decade
is that we have moved
beyond psychology,
psychiatry and neurology
and we've merged
with other disciplines.
Statistical analysis,
artificial intelligence,
machine learning,
even, you know,
material sciences,
information technology
with advances in technology
contributing to ever better,
faster and smarter
devices and techniques.
One of the things
that we're trying to do
is to really push
the boundaries of
the latest in science
and technology
to enable these portable
electroencephalogram systems
to open a new window on the
complex functioning
of our brain.
And, I wanted to
take a few moments
to share with you
and really show you
an insight into what my brain
actually looks like
in real-time.
So, if we switch over,
there you are. So, this is,
this device is picking
up my brain activity right now
and transmitting
it to a computer.
And, so what you're
able to see is
a data visualization tool
that localizes the activity
in different
functional brain areas.
So, when you see the frontal
part of my brain light up,
the frontal lobes
are responsible
for executive function,
conscious thoughts,
movements, attention,
planning, language, logic.
The side of my brains,
the temporal lobes
are responsible for
processing auditory
responses, memory.
And the back of my brain,
when you see
that part light up
the parietal and
occipital lobes,
that's actually responsible
for sensory integration
and visual processing.
And so through tools like this
we can actually have a window
into what's going on in
real-time,
and that allows us to
really start to piece together
the beneficial effects
of nature on the brain,
in a way that we haven't
really been able to...
to see in the past.
And, so with that
I am going to pass on to
Nalini to end our...
( applause )
Well, that's great.
I can't believe I just saw
my colleague's brain going on
but that was fantastic.
And really that's the
wonderful thing
about a collaboration
like ours.
There's so much sharing
and learning that goes on,
I've learned, for example,
that the different
parts of a neuron,
a single neuron,
one of billions
that occur in our brain,
they function
in a way to connect
the thoughts and the actions
and the knowledge that we have
within our bodies and outside,
outside our worlds.
And I'd like to share
with my colleagues
anything I can
tell them about trees
because that's what I study.
And I have been studying
forest trees for many years.
I study in the forest canopy.
I started 35 years ago
and that was a time
when we were pioneers
in the forest canopy,
where very few
people had ascended.
Well, the beautiful tapestry
of the intact forest canopy
is being destroyed
by many human activities.
And I became very
concerned about this.
The disturbances
of deforestation,
of forest fragmentation,
of conversion of primary
forest to agricultural land.
Another environmental problem
that I became very interested
in is the harvesting of
canopy dwelling mosses
for the horticulture trade.
This is a 300-million
dollar business.
And it wouldn't sound
so bad unless you realize that
it takes 30 years,
20 to 30 years
for these mosses to grow back
after they've been
stripped off
of old growth forest trees.
And as a scientist,
I felt that maybe I could
do something about this
environmental problem
and I realized
I couldn't stop the
collecting of mosses,
but perhaps I could learn
how to farm these mosses,
in order to bring down
the harvesting pressure
in these beautiful
old growth systems.
And it also seemed to me
that I needed help to do this
And it also seemed
to me that perhaps
people who didn't have access,
people who don't
have access to nature
or to these beautiful mosses
and this incredible
temperate rainforest
might be the best
possible partners.
And so I started
a program in 2005
to enlist the
help of prisoners,
of incarcerated men and women
to help me learn
how to grow mosses
for the horticulture trade.
They have time,
many of them have space,
you don't need sharp
tools to grow mosses.
And so in fact this turned out
to be a fabulous project.
The incarcerated men and women
enjoyed this project
and got something out of it
because they found
that they were contributing
to something larger
than themselves,
something larger
than the prison
in which they
were incarcerated.
Something as large
as planet Earth,
because they were
helping to reduce...
collecting pressure of
these old growth ecosystems.
And the supervisors
and superintendent
loved this project because
the men were occupied.
They were having better
social interactions.
Violent infractions
started going down.
And so they asked me
to organize more projects.
I started a science
lecture series
in this prison that
spread to others.
And from those lecture series
became the inspiration
for starting some
conservation projects.
These involved growing
endangered species,
prairie plants,
the Oregon spotted frog,
the Taylor checkerspot
butterfly
by the inmates behind bars.
When these animals
and plants were produced,
they were taken by our
collaborating conservation
groups
and used for restoration
projects in Washington state.
This was really
a win-win situation
for the men and women
that we were able to bring
these projects to
but I very soon realized
that I was missing
people in the prison,
in terms of people
who could be
involved with these projects.
That is, I was missing
the men and women
who were incarcerated far deep
in the bowels of the prison
system of the United States,
those that live in
solitary confinement.
Over 30,000,
some estimate it up as high
as 80,000 men and women
are incarcerated
in solitary confinement
in the United States.
This is a cell, 9 by 12.
All you can see is very
bare of really anything.
They're incarcerated in
this cell for 23 hours a day.
Their meals are
brought to them.
And one hour a day, they
are brought out by two guards
to their exercise rooms or
their recreational space,
which again is
a very bare room
with very little
in terms of stimulation,
and absolutely no
exposure to nature at all.
And it seemed
to me that maybe,
although we couldn't
bring in frogs and butterflies
and soil and plants,
that we might be able
to bring nature imagery
to these exercise cells.
So that for at
least one hour a day
they would be exposed
to some element
of nature and nature imagery.
We started this out at the
invitation of a wonderful,
oh, well, I don't know if I
can say wonderful prison,
but in any case, a prison
where wonderful people work,
the Snake River
Correctional Institution
in Ontario, Oregon.
They installed a
projector in one of the
exercise rooms in one
of the cellblocks there.
They were able to gather
natural history films
from the web and
various other places.
And so, right now
the men who are
in solitary confinement
can ask to see
one of the films
when they go into
their exercise room.
And there they can
choose one of the 30 films
that has been made
available to them.
And then they're
able to watch that film
and for that one hour a day
they're being exposed
to nature imagery.
We have some
anecdotal information
that this has
been very positive,
in terms of bringing
down stress and anxiety
but we have to do more work
in terms of understanding
how this might become
an intervention.
We need to understand
the real impacts of this
on the attitudes
and the behavior
of the inmates that
are exposed to it.
We also recognize
that it's not just
the incarcerated men
and women who are exposed
to this nature
deficit situation.
It's also the staff,
the officers and the people
who work in this environment
that undergo what
they call decomposition
of physical, emotional and
psychological behavior,
as they're removed from
nature and nature imagery.
This is true not only in
solitary confinement prisons
but increasingly
as Tierney pointed out,
in our own society.
People who work
in windowless offices
in cubicles like this,
people who have
jobs in tollbooths,
people who work
in military barracks.
My own mom who's 91 years old
and is in a senior
assisted living center
in Rockville, Maryland here
has very little
in the way of interaction
with nature or
nature imagery.
So, I think there's
tremendous potential
to think about the things that
Tierney and Tan
have talked about
and the kind of things
that we'd like to do,
to eventually
apply what we know
to the kinds of
populations that we will be
a part of increasingly
as time goes forward.
I think that our collaboration
has allowed us
to just sort of,
as Tierney said,
"put our toes into
the first little waves
of understanding
humans and the brain."
But I'd like to
just share with you
three of the
beginning conclusions
that we have come
up with so far.
First of all,
we've come to understand that
if we want to understand
nature and the brain
we must use both
the cognitive sides
of our ability to understand
as well as the emotional side.
Both of those are intertwined,
if we're to understand
nature and the brain.
Secondly,
we need to collaborate.
It's great to have this
threesome of colleagues,
but there are other fields
that must be drawn into this.
Neuroscience, ecopsychology,
sociology, all of these fields
must come together
and touch in points
where we can make contact
and help each other understand
this complexity of
nature and the brain.
And the third concluding idea
that we've come up with as
a result of our collaboration...
is that nature is necessary
for human social resilience,
that is, nature is
needed by everyone.
Thank you.
( applause )
( outro music )